nous sommes le 25 septembre bonjour
bienvenue et merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette nouvelle édition du journal
du vendredi voici les principaux titres
de l'actualité locale 26 septembre 1986
coluche lance sur l'antenne d'europe 1
un appel quelques mois plus tard
naissent les restos du coeur trente ans
plus tard neuf cent cinquante mille
personnes sont accueillies 128 millions
de repas distribués en france invité
pour en parler
michel mottin responsable communication
des restos dans les yvelines et des
smart days nom de code de l'opération
annuelle lancée par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines sur
le campus d' hec à jouy-en-josas
thématiques développées depuis ce
vendredi matin l'économie circulaire ou
comment réduire sans être gaspillé puis
nous reviendrons sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine comme chaque
vendredi des annonces autour de la coop
21 par la région ile de france au sommet
donc sur ce sommet mondial de
l'environnement à la fête musulmane de
l'aïd el kébir voilà pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité tout à l'heure dans ce
journal bonjour michel motin et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
bonjour responsable communication des
restos du coeur dans les yvelines c'est
avec vous que nous allons revenir sur
l'appel des trente ans il ya trente ans
coluche lancé cet appel écouter et cet
extrait des archives d'europe 1
j'ai une petite idée comme ça si des
fois il ya des marques qui m'entendent
je fais un petit peu de publicité tous
les jours s'il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés par pons aurait une cantine
gratuite qu'on pourrait commencer par
faire à paris par exemple que on
étalerait après dans les grandes villes
de france
nous on est prêt à aider une entreprise
comme ça qu'ils feraient
un resto par exemple courait comme
ambition départ de père demi produits
couverts par jour rapidement
c'est ainsi que naissaient les restos du
coeur 1985 qui a 60 à peu près de 900
personnes qui sont accueillis millions
de repas servis en tout cas en 1985 oui
parce que les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
sont beaucoup plus inquiétant 950 mille
personnes accueillies elle 128 millions
de repas servis alors justement comment
vous percevez ces chiffres est ce que
c'est une satisfaction de voir que
l'idée des restos a été un vrai succès
ou est-ce qu'il ya aussi malgré tout une
déception de voir l'échec des politiques
des différents gouvernements face à face
à la pauvreté
c'est vrai que l'on constate quand même
qu'il y a trente ans de précarité
pour nous c'est plus un échec qu'une
satisfaction
il est exact que leur 1985 comme vous
l'avez justement dit nous avions 70000
personnes accueillies la fin à plus d'un
million donc en fin de compte c'est
extrêmement difficile
ça veut dire quoi du gouvernement n'ont
pas trouvé de solution ce sont peut-être
aussi trop appuyé sur l'idée des restos
se disant ça existe pas profitons-en
oui c'est possible mais bon la précarité
a toujours existé aussi qu'en fin de
compte on peut pas mettre l'accent sûr
sûr sûr le gouvernement soit sur les
gouvernements
ça serait faux de disparaître
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une institution
malheureusement oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai on souhaiterait disparaître c'est
certain je suis sûr que coluche à
l'époque ne pensez pas que 30 ans après
nous aurions de tels chiffres
mais bon faut faire face notre
nos accueillis ont beaucoup changé nous
avons on va peut-être en reparler mais
sur le profil de nos accueilli on va
venir
ce sont les gens sont plus les mêmes
donc en fin de compte on fait face et
puis on essaye d'assumer 26 septembre 4
lors de l'appel en 10 70 85 vous étiez
ou dont 85 points
je travaillais mépor reste oranje
étaient j'avais ma propre société et
vous l'avez entendu cet appel oui
absolument c'est mon époque
oui c'est mon époque quand j'ai été tout
de suite vous avez système validé oui
absolument
et c'était un personnage que que
j'aimais tellement qu'en fin de compte
un certain nombre d'années après que
lorsque ma carrière s'est arrêtée que
j'ai souhaité faire autre chose j'ai été
tout naturellement vers les restos du
coeur vous l'avez dit en trente ans les
restos mme beaucoup changé sur le profil
des personnes qui sont accueillis
aujourd'hui on retrouve beaucoup de
jeunes beaucoup de seniors aussi les
femmes seules
oui absolument voyez on trouve oui parce
qu'ils ont faim de contes on trouve des
jeunes parce que les jeunes de 18 à 25
ans mais ils ont aucune aide
donc ils viennent nous voir voilà on les
accueille c'est pas facile du tout pour
eux nous avons de plus en plus que nous
avions pas il ya trente ans des familles
monoparentales ce a suivi l'évolution de
la société absolument c'est la cena
sidaoui la situation actuelle et puis on
va on peut certainement également
revenir
nous avons beaucoup de l'iran bien sûr
donc c'est
nous avons des personnes retraitées qui
ont une retraite mais la retraite est
tellement faibles qu'ils n'ont plus les
moyens de se nourrir donc qui viennent
nous voir ils viennent nous accueillir
et nos activités ont effectivement
énormément évolué depuis 30 ans lors de
la création il y avait une centaine de
centres d aide alimentaire on est passé
aujourd'hui à 2100 centre et certains
exposent une aide à l'insertion aussi
parce que la façon d'accueillir a changé
on ne fait pas uniquement de l'aide
alimentaire aux restos absolument voilà
c'est vous avez tout à fait raison il ya
trente ans encore pas trop revenir sur
le passé mais l'activité des restos
c'était la distribution alimentaire
trente ans après c'est la distribution
alimentaire
mais c'est l'aide à la personne je suis
y avait un pourcentage à donner il se
dirait que l'aide alimentaire c'est 60 %
de notre activité le reste et l'aide à
la personne
qu'est ce que vous faites dans les
yvelines justement quels sont les les
centres est ce qu'il ya des centres
spécifiques dhombres recherche d'emploi
conseil budgétaire liés aux droits déjà
dans les yvelines nous avons 22 centres
de dissolution et qui sont des centres
effectivement d'activité donc il ya
toutes les activités proprement dit
qu'on retrouve au national dans les
activités dans les yvelines et nous
avons une nouvelle activité d'ailleurs
que nous avons démarré il ya deux mois
nous venons de signer une convention
avec le bateau delebarre au pardon le
barreau de versailles pour l'aide à la
justice aux droits et c'est une activité
qui qui démarre donc il faut encore des
bénévoles il faut justement ces
bénévoles ils sont près de 70 mille en
france ils sont nombreux dans les îles
aussi nous sommes presque 1000 et séance
en constante augmentation est ce que
c'est ça c'est très stable c'est très
stable il ya ya un turnover assez
important il y a grosso modo 250
bénévoles qui parquent de chaque chaque
année il y en a 250 qui reviennent donc
on est depuis quelques années
toujours autour de 1000 personnes 1000
bénévoles
alors que la demande augmente donc les
bénévoles sont les bienvenus si vous
nous écoutez aujourd'hui vous fait
vraiment un appel aux bénévoles
j'aime autant vous restez sur sur le
plateau vous êtes invités de ce vendredi
du journal on va évoquer le reste de
l'actualité du jour est ce que vous
connaissez l'économie circulaire non eh
bien vous allez découvrir le sens prince
est un principe économique qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre du développement durable
l'objectif c'est de produire des biens
et des services tout en limitant la
consommation gaspillage des matières
premières de l'eau des sources d'énergie
par exemple transformer les déchets en
matières premières est utilisé pour la
conception d'autres produits aujourd'hui
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines organisée son
événement annuel des smart d'oeil sur ce
thème vous envoyer les images c'était
dans les locaux d' hec à jouy en josas
dans les yvelines il y aurait 3700
établissements gravitant autour de cette
économie au coeur de la transition
écologique et énergétique mieux
appréhender le concept connaître les
innovations les réussites comprendre le
marché ces opportunités
c'est en jeu c'était tout l'objectif de
ce rendez vous l'objectif des journées
que l'on organise qui s'appelle desmare
dates sont tout simplement pour informer
les entreprises du territoire et les
collectivités du territoire sur des
évolutions technologiques
j'en avais ont fait l'année dernière le
en fait lesparre d'oeil sur les objets
connectés
cette année nous avons pensé justement
que l'économie circulaire qui est une
spécialisation de la chambre de commerce
de versailles yvelines et
un élément intéressant justement à
présenter et d'avoir des échanges autour
justement de cette économie circulaire
et l'évolution attendue viennent de nous
rejoindre en plateau à présent un jean
françois le saux bonjour vous êtes
enseignant à montigny le bretonneux et
femmes nos klein bonjour et bienvenue
vous êtes auteur de cet ouvrage de père
inconnu et vous allez travailler
ensemble puisque vous avez souhaité que
l'auteur vienne au début de l'année 2016
rencontrer vos élèves dans votre
établissement il sait des cartes pour
parler des camps de rééducation vietnam
au milieu des années 70 pouvez nous
présenter nous expliquer un petit peu ce
projet qui va vous unir pour la suite de
l'année oui alors en fait j'ai eu la
chance de découvrir son livre parce que
ma femme est vietnamienne et j'ai été
tellement passionné moi qui lis pas
toujours des ouvrages
autre que des sciences et je me suis dit
hé bien il faut que je fasse découvrir
ses oeuvres à mes collègues et également
à mes élèves
vous avez réagi à cette demande
justement intervenir dans un
établissement vous êtes souvent
sollicité pas trop puisque mon livre
vient de sortir seulement
mais bon c'est pain c'est une grande
joie pour moi de pouvoir parler surtout
aux jeunes
moi j'étais quand même bon à l'époque
j'étais enseignant et donc ça ça me ça
me tente beaucoup de pouvoir dialoguer
avec des jeunes et surtout parlé du
contenu de mon livre et surtout d'un
d'une période que je pense que les
jeunes ont tendance à oublier
on va parler du contenu de cet ouvrage
mais quand même préciser que vous êtes
aujourd'hui à saint quentin en yvelines
parce que vous allez rencontrer le
proviseur et les autres enseignants de
l'établissement pour mettre au point un
petit peu le projet dans les grandes
lignes ça va se passer comment
concrètement ont étudié l'ouvragé
interagir il ya plusieurs aspects j'ai
une collègue de français
sylvie roger qui va faire travailler les
élèves de seconde
de la même classe que moi sur un aspect
on va faire en fait pierre et jean de
maupassant et le livre donc les
comparaisons entre l'aspect vécu et de
femmes note l'année puis ce roman de
pierre et jean donc là un aspect
littéraire et puis un smirnov en
histoire qui va travailler sur cet
aspect cette fois-ci civique et donc va
revenir sur les boat people sur les
camps de réfugiés sur les camps de
concentration au vietnam et donc sur le
vécu de femmes noclin et donc c'est
vraiment une chance inouïe d'avoir
quelqu'un tels que tel que lui et qui
est accepté de venir parce que pour moi
c'était vraiment inespéré
on va parler du contenu de cet ouvrage à
présent tout en précisant bien
évidemment que nous vous suivrons dans
cette aventure avec vos élèves et qu'on
aura l'occasion de détailler encore un
petit peu plus votre parcours votre
témoignage vous êtes né à saïgon en 1944
de merville même y est né de père
français
justement c'est un petit peu le récit de
cette recherche du père dans cet ouvrage
à perdre vous n'avez pas connu
oui pourquoi parce que ça se passait
très souvent à l'époque mon père était
un officier de l'armée française
mais bon c'était l'âme et du temps de la
colonisation et pendant le deuxième
guerre mondiale il y avait la coupure
entre les colonies et le métropole et
donc pas mal de d'officier ou ou de
soldats français à l'époque on se
mettait en couple avec une vietnamienne
bon c'était le cas de bon bien que ma ma
mère avec avait exigé des cérémonies de
deux traditionnels impôts le mariage
mais il n'y a pas eu de formalités à la
française et donc après mon père a été
tué quand j'avais un an par les japonais
demandant ce qu'on appelle le coup de
force du 9 mars 1945
est ce qu'il a été identifié en super
par la suite en évidemment en fait il
est légalement inconnu oui mais je sais
exactement qui s'est glissée seulement
sur d'après les dires de ma mère mais
pas vous pas vraiment qui il est
réellement qu'elle et sa famille ou est
ce qu'elle est née je n'en savais rien
et donc j'ai écrit ce livre de père
inconnu pour parler un peu de com angers
comment j'ai tout essayé pour retrouver
les traces de mon père voilà on en
comprend plus sociation de
fonctionnement de la société parce
qu'après vous avez été adopté par les
pouviez tu n'as rien de votre votre mère
il a réellement reçu une éducation
vietnamien et être métisse n'était pas
forcément bien vu aussi c'est ce que
vous expliquez dans les années 50 vous
fait vos études
la guerre éclate aussi mobilisez vous
dire vous êtes pharmacien aussi après la
défaite vous êtes un cas célèbre
incarcéré pardon dans un camp de
rééducation peut s'attarder sur cette
période comment ça s'est passé cette
période d'incarcération bon c'est très
bon je pense que c'est évident que c'est
épouvantable pas bon j'ai été dans ce
camp de rééducation parce que bon comme
vous dites et pharmaciens et tout de
suite après être après mes études j'ai
été mobilisés dans l'armée puisque
c'était la guerre et au bout de 4h et
j'ai été libéré et je suis devenu
raciste dans la faculté de pharmacie de
saigon et en 75 après la victoire des
communistes et la réunification du pays
bon au départ c'était pendant le
un premier mois s'était encore bon la
gare un peu l'euphorie parce qu'on ne
voyait pas qu'ils avaient le bain de
sang qui a été annoncé comme au cambodge
par exemple avec les bons avec le mérou
jeu c'était incroyable mais au vietnam
ce n'était pas comme ça
par contre après tout les anciens
officiers de l'armée du sud et aussi les
offres aux fonctionnaires ont été
envoyés dans des camps de rééducation et
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que
j'y ai passé seulement quatre mois alors
que celui qui est passé faire qui est
resté le plus longtemps ça fait 17 ans
1700 sans jugement sans savoir pourquoi
il reste 17 ans maurice m et 20 cents
savoir jamais quand est-ce qu'il va
revenir et moi pendant les quatre mois
j'aime dire bon c'est rien par rapport à
17 ans mais pendant les quatre mois
mon épouse ne sais même pas si je suis
encore vivant ou mort ou est ce que je
suis c'était c'était l'angoissé
je veux dire les premiers mois si telle
angoisse pour les centaines de milliers
des pousses comme la mienne et vous avez
quitté votre pays après cette partie
avec ces boat people cinq ans après ce
qui n'est pas sans rappeler l'actualité
aussi du moment lorsqu'on voit arriver
ces réfugiés qui fuient la syrie qui
free qui fuit l'irak
comment vous réagissez quand vous voyez
ces images justement de sa blessure ne
reviendra vous remémore ces sites vous
ignorent ces boat people en fait je dois
faire
un petit point parce que je ne suis pas
parti en bons people j'ai vu parti
officiellement mais dans ma famille
surtout la famille de ma femme
tout le monde est parti je connais donc
parfaitement les rouages comment ça
s'est passé
et donc quand j'ai vu les à la télé les
gens qui étaient dans une petite
chaloupe avec un passeur qui n'était
même pas présent sur la chaloupe et qui
qui a fait 12 à demers et puis le moteur
est tombé en panne
ça me rappelle exactement ce que mes
proches et mes compatriotes et mes
proches ont vécu dans les la fin des
années 70 début des années 80 il y avait
des centaines de milliers et leur voyage
c'était en général en moyenne de deux à
trois jours il y en a qui ont passé un
mois en mer avant d'être secourue il y
en a combien qui sont mao n'en sais rien
mais on estime une proportion importante
quoi on l'a bien compris en vous
écoutant le but c'est d'humaniser
l'histoire avec cet ouvrage montrer
comment vous vous êtes construit à
travers l histoire de plusieurs pays
comment vous vos compatriotes ont évolué
vos contemporains
vous reviendrez au japon parce que en
effet les élèves ne peuvent qu'être
grandi en voyant un tel un tel courage
un tel optimisme aussi et c'est une
vraie chance pour nos élèves de voir
quelqu'un qui écrit si bien en français
parce qu'il faut vraiment se plonger
dans son livre et se rendre compte à
quel point il a eu un
quelque chose de détails et il a été
donc docteur en pharmacie
il a fait de la physique moi je suis
professeur de physique moi j étais
bobino visite à il est guitariste
émérite il l'a fait aussi de l'histoire
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui est très
complet et très simple en même temps et
je crois que c'est là qu'apparaît la
caractéristique de d'hommes
exceptionnels de père inconnu récit sur
le vietnam de la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle merci à tous les deux
peut-être juste une réaction michel
moteur parce que parler des boat people
on parlait des réfugiés aussi ces
réfugiés ces migrants aux restos du
coeur vous vous les accueillez vous les
voyez venir aussi
oui si on parle des migrants
actuellement c'est pas encore arrivés au
nez vous attendez à accueillir
américains s'attendent heureusement pas
absolument suivant et il va falloir
faire face
vous avez déjà prévu vous pensé parce
qu'on parle chaque année des difficultés
pour trouver suffisamment de méditation
nourriture pour faire face donc en fin
de compte on sait qu'on va avoir
beaucoup de monde vers combien on ne
sait pas mais bon c'est pas c'est pas
une nouveauté et on est habitué à avoir
des migrants donc c'est une continuité
et on va les accueillir comme nous
accueillons les migrants actuelle est ce
que nous activons continuellement qui
ont aussi atteint mais j'aime autant
vous restez en plateau merci donc à tous
les deux je vous laisse aller préparer
un petit peu ce projet avec les élèves
dans l'établissement au lycée descartes
le temps d'un merci gilles bellemare de
l'actualité de la semaine à présent
comme chaque vendredi nous revenons nous
revenons à présent sur l'actualité de la
semaine écoulée pour recommencer résumé
en images avec ce montage ce jeudi matin
les musulmans étaient appelés à venir
prier à partir de 8h à montigny le
bretonneux plus de 200 fidèles se sont
réunis au gymnase roger rivière ce
rendez vous une fois la prière terminée
direction l'abattoir mobile de trappes
sur place les fidèles viennent récupérer
un mouton commander sur internet
ici on peut observer le sec lévis rituel
de l'animal
cette décision de l'état de réduire de
30% les fonds alloués aux collectivités
locales un pacte nécessairement leur
fonctionnement sur la commune de poissy
la dotation de 6 millions quatre cent
mille euros en 2014 passera à 4 millions
huit cent mille euros en 2015 la ville
de plaisir quand à elle enregistre une
baisse de 1 million d'euros
certains services vont être redéployés
vont baisser
on va essayer de faire mieux ou appareil
à égalité de dépenses avoir à baisses de
dépenses mais si une fois ces économies
faites
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que la
hausse d'impôts nous serons obligés
d'augmenter les impôts je crois que le
conseil général ou départementales du
nord vient d'annoncer qu'il ne pourrait
pas payer le rsa ce qu'est la principale
dépense d'un conseil départemental à
partir du 1er octobre
il ya d'autres conseils départementaux
qui sont dans cette situation enfin
c'est très grave ce qui serait tout
simplement car il me se retrouve dans
aucun à d autres candidats il le dit
très clairement puisqu'on lui a posé la
question écouter ils sont engagés dans
une espèce de guerre de chefs de nos
sympathisants d'abord mais au-delà
l'ensemble des français mme mba
n'apprécie pas remplacé ce qu'ils me
disent tous les jours deuxièmement je
trouve que les projets qui sont
défendues aujourd'hui sont sur une ligne
qui est très libérale beaucoup trop à
mon goût
le centre de loisirs des bruyères les
halles du marché
sujet préoccupe les clés sien depuis
plusieurs mois leur avenir est au centre
de discussions
la décision de déplacer le centre dans
une école de passe pas pour certains
d'entre eux ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à cette réunion publique
d'information egea à nouveau en grève ce
matin les salariés du site de montigny
le bretonneux se sont mobilisés contre
le plan de restructuration de
l'entreprise
les syndicats ont organisé une journée
d'action intersites rassemblant les
trois autres sites français
saint-apollinaire nom et château thierry
on est face à une situation incroyable
puisque l'entreprise ge a fait des
bénéfices absolument considérable n'a
aucun problème financier
et ben on met à la porte les gens pour
des raisons qui sont purement
financières
25 personnes toutes les aires nous aider
nos parents nos enfants nous sommes tous
concernés
leur
alors nous devons tous agir maintenant
la coop 21 qui débutera bientôt à paris
doit permettre d'aboutir à un nouvel
accord international sur le climat en
cas de sud en cas de succès quels
changements pour les franciliens c'est
la question posée par la région ile de
france
un rapport a été dévoilé ce matin par
jean paul huchon il a été remis au
président de la république environnement
avec la cap 21 la maladie d'alzheimer
également avec la mobilisation autour de
cette maladie et puis la colère des
maires voilà quelques-uns des sujets qui
ont été à traiter cette semaine est ce
qu'il ya un sujet dans l'actualité que
ce soit locale ou nationale qui vous a
interpellé plus particulièrement le
reportage que vous venez de faire sur ce
livre qui m'a un peu bouleversé les
témoignages qu'on vient d'entendre jouer
quand vient d'entendre et je vais
acheter ce livre
et pouvoir effectivement mieux
comprendre vous êtes avec nous
aujourd'hui parce que demain à samedi ce
sera ça fera trente ans tout juste que
coluche lançait son appel sur les ondes
d'europe 1 et à cette occasion il y aura
des portes ouvertes dans certains
centres vous allez jouer la transparence
complète vous allez montrer accueillir
les gens sains petit peu sur le principe
des journées du patrimoine puisque je
fais partie du patrimoine
un peu oui c'est exact alors nous allons
faire effectivement une après midi
portes ouvertes demain
notre entrepôt qui se trouve qu'un
support rue du président-kennedy donc là
nous aurons les personnes qui vont venir
nous voir pour l'occasion de discuter
avec tous les responsables de toutes nos
activités que nous présentons dans les
yvelines
donc ça va de la distribution
alimentaire à l'aide de juridictionnelle
au resto bébé etc des reins qui aidera
toutes les activités seront là et s'il
ya des gens qui veulent venir et puis
voir un petit peu pour s'inscrire en
tant que bénévole ils seront bien sûr
les bienvenus on les accueilleront et il
y à pas durant cet après midi un petit
goûter tout simple qui sera servi la
campagne d'hiver pour les restos va
débuter au mois novembre
oui fin novembre fin novembre jusque là
comme d'habitude pour cette semaine
jusqu'à mi mars et on n'en parle pas
assez souvent mais aussi les campagnes
d'été qui sont menées aux restos du
coeur j'aurais juste qu'on termine avec
ça vous continuer à accueillir les
populations les plus en difficulté
pendant l'été oui oui tout à fait et si
cette année ça a été même c'est
exceptionnel car nous avons testé
l'ouverture de centres dans la région de
trappes pendant juillet et août
parce qu'en fin de compte nous recevions
beaucoup d'appels en juillet et août et
nous pouvions pas répondre donc nous
avons ouvert quatre centres dans la
région de trappes pour accueillir ces
gens et c'était très très très
enrichissant et on va essayer de
continuer sur d'autres centres mais il
faut des bénévoles toujours marseillais
race et de la célébrité du collège et
des dos pour qu'on puisse continuer à
assumer cette dissolution
merci michel lamotte un responsable
communication des restos du coeur dans
le département des yvelines d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce journal du vendredi
et puis juste pour terminer l'actualité
cette semaine c est également cette fête
de l'aïd el kébir fait la plus
importante de la communauté musulmane
retour sur cette organisation avec le
reportage de mickaël millero l'aïd
el-kébir l'une des fêtes les plus
importantes de l'islam a débuté
aujourd'hui ce jeudi matin les musulmans
étaient appelés à venir prier à partir
de 8h à montigny le bretonneux plus de
200 fidèles se sont réunis au gymnase
roger rivière pour ce rendez vous l'imam
a notamment insisté sur la situation des
migrants
le message clé de cette allocution de
l'imam seont faveur pour déjà pour
sensibiliser la communauté à cette fête
il faut partager avec les systèmes les
pauvres il faut penser aux démunis à
ceux qui souffrent dans les autres pays
donc c'est ça le message clé et c'est le
message et c'est les fondements de
l'islam de tolérance et de paix une fois
la prière terminée direction l'abattoir
mobile de trappes sur place les fidèles
viennent récupérer un mouton commander
sur internet
ici on peut observer le sacrifice rituel
de l'animal c'est une tradition qu'on a
grandi avec et c'est une tradition qu'on
a pris avec notre religion
depuis qu'on était petit du coup ça
important qu'ont assisté en transmis à
ça à nos enfants le bouton est ensuite
découpé par des professionnels la
carcasse entière et donner directement
clients quelques minutes après sa mort
val d'oise faire barbecue avec les
enfants on va passer la journée on va
faire la tête on va le partager en trois
tiers un tiers c'est pour les
nécessiteux un tiers pour la famille où
on partage avec la famille les amis et
lin tiers pour la petite famille qui est
la nôtre
voilà c'est c'est l'esprit dans lequel
tout musulman doit vivre cette fête
cette grande fête l'aïd el kébir durera
jusqu'à ce samedi à trappes plus de 1400
bouton été sacrifiés pour ce cinquième
pilier de l'islam ont rendez vous lundi
aux mêmes horaires pour un nouveau
journal dédié à l'actualité est local
l'actualité des yvelines ce sera
présentée par florane parfait quant à
moi je vous retrouve vendredi prochain
pour un nouveau journal de la semaine
très bon week end